we are all familiar with the concept of
absolute value it simply tells us the
non-negative value of the number it
ignores its sign the absolute value of
two is written like this with two
vertical lines on each end so the
absolute value ignores the sign of two
and gives the answer as to what about
the absolute value of a negative number
say absolute value of -5 the definition
does not change it ignores the sign and
gives the answer as five what is the
absolute value of minus ten by three the
definition does not change even if it's
a fraction it ignores the sign and gives
the answer as 10 by three on a number
line the absolute value tells us how far
the number is from zero to for example
is two units away from zero minus five
is five units away from the zero but is
this concept of absolute value as easy
when it's applied to equations say we
have something like absolute value of x
minus five plus five is equal to 25 how
do we find the value of x here try it
out okay to simplify it a bit let's
transpose this five to the other side we
get absolute value of X minus five equal
to twenty now it gets interesting this X
minus five which lies inside the
absolute value sign can be 20 or minus
20 that's because absolute value of 20
as well as the absolute value of minus
20 will both equal 20 X minus 5 can
either be equal to 20 or it can be equal
to minus 20 this equation boiled down to
these two mini equations based on this
equation we get XS
25 and based on this one we get X as -15
we got two values for X to know if both
these values are correct
let's try substituting them in place of
X and see if we get 20 we are looking at
this equation now substituting 25 in
place of X we get absolute value of 25
minus 5 that equals absolute value of 20
which is also 20 this is equal to the
right hand side X equal to 25 is correct
now let's try substituting minus 15 here
we get absolute value of minus 15 minus
5 that equals absolute value of minus 20
and ignoring the sign we get the answer
as 20 it is the right hand side minus 15
is also the correct answer that was
interesting but let's ask ourselves one
question how many of us actually check
the answer
very few I admit even I never checked my
answers in my exams but here I am
specifically asking you to check the
answer even though you don't like it I'm
not giving you a choice if you think
this was easy try solving the next
equation absolute value of x plus 6 is
equal to 3x plus 2 based on what we just
learnt the expression inside the modulus
could be 3x plus 2 or minus 3x plus 2x
plus 6 is equal to 3x plus 2 or X plus 6
can be minus 3x plus 2 solving this
equation gives us the value of x as 2
and solving this equation gives us the
value of x as -2 we got two values for X
here most of you all would have got
these two values for x
but did you check your answer did you
substitute these values in place of X
and see if this equation is satisfied
let's check our answer take the X equal
to two case first the left-hand side
will equal the absolute value of 2 plus
6 that equals 8 and the right-hand side
will be 3 times 2 plus 2 which also
equals 8 both these values are equal
which is why X is equal to 2 is a
correct solution now we can jump to the
second case of X equal to minus 2 the
left-hand side will be the absolute
value of minus 2 plus 6 that gives us 4
and the right-hand side will be 3 x
minus 2 plus 2 and that gives us minus 4
not for here the left-hand side is not
equal to the right-hand side
so X equal to minus 2 is not a solution
to this equation X equal to 2 is the
only correct solution and not this one
good now you know why I asked you to
check your answer in absolute value
questions
you